Speaker 1: In 2023.
If you still support Donald Trump.
You deserve to have every penny drained from
your bank account if you're giving them money,
if that's what happens to you or what you
decide to do.
Donald Trump's fans sent him a million and
a half dollars in three days after he falsely
predicted he would be arrested on Tuesday.
A fool and their money are soon parted.
Does that apply here?
Business Insider reports.
Trump wasn't arrested, but he got a big fundraising
boost, raising $1.5 million in the three days
after saying he'd be arrested.
That's nearly double the daily average he
got in the weeks before and after launching
his 2024 bid.
The campaign confirmed the sum to Fox News.
The money was said to be raised from grassroots
donations.
Raising about 500,000 a day is about double
what Trump was previously averaging.
The Trump campaign brought in 11.8 million
in the six weeks before the announcement,
which averages out to about 280,000 a day.
In the six weeks after Trump's announcement,
he raised about 226,000 a day.
But then he wrote, They're going to arrest
me.
We need to protest, Take the nation back.
Soros Deep State conspiracy.
And on and on and on.
And then he started including videos like
the one we just looked at, talking about how
he will dismantle the deep state he started,
including those videos inside of fundraising
emails.
And he said, we need your support.
Donate so we can do this.
If you're not doing well, don't send any money.
But if you can, if you can afford it, please
send me some money.
It is in.
Is it pejorative to say that you would have
to be moronic to fall for this at this point
in time?
Now you might be saying.
What on earth motivates an individual to give
money to a billionaire because they claim
they're about to be arrested and argue that
they are going to dismantle the so-called
deep state?
What on earth would motivate someone to give
that individual money?
And you have to remember that this is a cult.
It is a cult where some in the cult believe
that Donald Trump was sent by God to save
the United States of America from a cabal
of Democratic pedophiles.
If you believe that.
It's not a very far stretch to say you're
going to spend a little bit of money.
And that is a big part of understanding what
is going on here.
And like I said, at this point, if you are
still a Trump supporter in 2023, it's it's
really buyer beware.
And the downside, of course, is I don't want
to see people hurt.
And for a lot of these folks donating money,
it's probably their Social Security money
that's going to Trump based on the average,
you know, the disproportionately advanced
age of Trump supporters and the financial
reality of many of these folks.
The other aspect to this, of course, is that
there's a long history.
I mean, go back to the Tea Party.
You can go back longer, but at least in the
modern era, go back to the Tea Party and you
will remember people who will never benefit
from lowering taxes on the rich, voting in
favor of candidates who want to lower taxes
on the rich.
Why?
It doesn't make sense.
It's the same thing with Trump supporting
a guy who isn't going to do anything that's
going to help you.
Jonathan Haidt has really done a lot of very
good research into this.
It is not about voting for what I think is
best.
For me, it's about voting for what I have
been convinced or tricked into believing.
This is now my editorializing of it.
What I have.
If I can be tricked into believing that what's
best for my entire group is to support someone
like Trump or a candidate that will lower
taxes on the rich, I will vote that way for
group cohesion, even if most of the members
of that group won't actually benefit for the
thing that they are voting in favor of.
You have to understand that to understand
why someone at this point would say, I'll
donate to Trump and I'll vote for Trump, even
though he's supposedly a billionaire and his
policies won't actually do anything for me.
Read Jonathan Height's work on that and it'll
be very illuminating.
Trump capitalizing on the arrest claim.
Will he pay his lawyers?
I don't know.
Will he actually get arrested next week?